さあ今回は主に言葉のお話なんですけれども 前回マウントという言葉があると言いました
これは一番最初のレンダリングの時に仮想ドームを作って それを本物のドームにそっくりそのまま反映させるというものでした
でこのマウントという言葉は今言ったように 仮想ドーム全体に対しても使うんですけれども
一方でコンポーネント単位でも使ったりします
どういうことかっていうと 例えば今この仮想ドームをコンポーネント単位で考えると
例えばこんな風に区切ることができますよね
この区切り方は何でもいいんですけれども 今回libタグのコンポーネントとテキストのコンポーネントと
h1タグとテキストがあるコンポーネントの 3つになるように区切るとします
でこの時に例えばパッチが起こって 新たに全く新しいコンポーネントが1つ付け足された場合
例えばpタグとかテキストを含んだコンポーネントが vifディレクティブとかでフォルスがトゥルーになってくっついた
みたいな時 この時はもちろん本物のドームにもパッチの処理で反映はされますが
この赤色のコンポーネントにとって見てみれば これが初めての一番最初のレンダリングですよね
こういう時にもこのコンポーネントがマウントしたという言い方をしたりします
だからマウントという言葉は仮想ドーム全体に対して最初のレンダリングをする時と
各コンポーネントに対して最初にレンダリングする時の2つの状況で使うことがあるんですね
一応ここを知っておいてください
またコンポーネントに関してはこんな風に
例えば vifディレクティブとかが逆にトゥルーからフォルスみたいになって消えるということもありますよね
このことを逆にそのコンポーネントがアンマウントしたと言ったりします
ぜひこの言葉も知っておいてください
その上で今言ったマウントとかアンマウントをコンポーネントがした時に
何か特定の処理ができたら便利そうですよね
実はそれをする方法がありまして
それについてを次のレクチャーで紹介したいと思います